johnny depp is ready to move on after
winning his defamation case against his
ex-wife amber hurd a source tells e.t
he's looking forward to his future
especially his career if i've gained
some degree of success in this industry
i'm really it's it's been it's been very
it's been very good to me on wednesday a
jury ruled in johnny's favor awarding
him 15 million dollars in damages
deciding he was in fact defamed by
amber's 2018 op-ed in the washington
post do you find that mr depp has proven
all the elements of defamation
answer yes the source says following the
verdict johnny is feeling really good
and positive quote he feels like things
are on the upswing for him and like he
cleared his name he's looking forward to
the future both personally and
professionally and feels like he got his
career back
and now johnny's focus seemingly on
music that's johnny stepping out with
guitarist jeff beck in glasgow scotland
rocking a plaid coat black jeans and a
beanie johnny's been on the road with
jeff for his uk tour the two are set to
hit the stage together at glasgow royal
concert hall friday night marking his
fourth appearance with the rocker
showing off his guitar skills
[Music]
but let's pivot to amber and how she's
doing following the trial our source
says the actress has been really
distraught and upset trying to lay low
and take care of herself and she's got
family by her side including her sister
whitney who was there every step of the
way through the trial the source adds
she feels really sad and overwhelmed
it's just a very difficult time in
general has mr deb proven by a greater
weight of the evidence that question the
statement was made or published by ms
heard
answer yes
but for amber she's willing to give it
one last shot by appealing the decision
elaine how is she today what is her next
move she's right well her next move is
appeal there were heartbroken she is
heartbroken and one of the first things
that she said when she came back from
the verdict when we went into the
conference room was i am so sorry to all
these women that said that yes she felt
like she had let down all of these women
because she had more evidence than most
people do and yet they still didn't
believe her
you